yo what is going on guys so this is the
beginning of the video I just ended off
the last one and we have 13.7 mil in the
bank going to go ahead and show you guys
real quick so there we are 13.8 my bad
but uh we're going to get this episode
started off so let's go ahead and uh do
some stuff I don't know what I want to
do yet but we'll figure it out by the
way lied about how much money I had I
had another 500k in the G so uh yeah and
there we go that's why uh if you guys
watched the previous episode I had a
medium clue that I had to do uh from
trials for and uh decided to drop it
once I got this task so uh let's go
ahead and do it all right chest time
give me something bad here we go like
six clue or something on the account
fourth 38k though I'll take it I mean
you know it's not Ranger boots but look
a we go another clue scroll
and G Gish fire lighter whatever I mean
nothing but there we go and there we go
41 Slayer another level for the uh video
I guess but uh yeah not too bad this
pretty cool um all the medium Clues
definitely makes it worth doing all
right next test let's see what we got
and something good please that's really
that is really good oh my God we're
going to do this in the wilderness we're
going to get a ring of wealth eye and
get some hard Clues I probably won't be
able to finish them but they'll give me
stuff to aim for realistically the only
one I for sure wouldn't finish would be
the Legends Guild one because all right
five step medium clue kind of annoying
but let's see if it paid out and I mean
I guess I'll take it and there we go I
think we're literally like seven kills
into the into the into the uh task so
there we go someone's over here
hopefully yeah he's just chilling which
is good um weird old man outside Cal
fight there we can do it let's let's go
but I have to go into this little area I
don't even remember what quest this is
but I know that there's probably a
little Trilogy of quests honestly so uh
we're going to get on that all right so
to do this I need to uh be able to start
Watchtower I believe and I don't know if
I need these stats to actually start
Watchtower but I'm going to head and get
them anyways since I'm going to need to
get them at some point so going to go
ahead and get 40 Mining and 14 herblore
all right little while later we have uh
40 Mining and 16 heror so time to go
ahead and finish this clue scroll
finally I doubt I'll do this too much
but there we go look at that over on my
main account right now just got a
spectral no fiveman split does so I mean
it's it's eh it's eh all right so uh
while I was just afking and doing some
Corp I decided to go ahead and use some
big bones so uh got 53 prayer I don't
know how much farther I'll go with this
but uh yeah it's not too shabby you know
just getting up some levels there we go
another odium Ward made so this is
another 500k uh the margins are still
really low if you actually want to try
and buy the uh the shards but uh yeah
all right so uh Ferro scepter I found
over on my main have like a 400k margin
so I'm going to go ahead and flip those
for a little bit hopefully um on top of
that I think I'm just going to do some
herb lore since I'm level 16 it's a
pretty quick skill and it helps get the
total level up so why not all right so
uh second like even second all right so
second inventory of actually doing
prayer or uh super strength not even
super all right so second inventory of
doing strength potions and we already
had this Ferro scepter buy so I think I
can sell it on for around
7225 I think is what we're just going to
go for I think can get more out of it
but I'd rather just be able to flip them
quick if I can get 300K margin all right
so there we go finally have prayer
potions unlocked just got that a little
bit ago but now up to 40 heror which is
really nice um one thing also with
getting heror that'll be really nice is
I can make on finish potions which
sometimes have just insane profit I even
made a video on it and it still has
insane margins so I'm pretty happy about
that and uh can't wait to be able to do
some uh make some money that way all
right so I did actually finally sell on
the Ferro scepter as you guys can see
was able to make well you guys can't see
it but I was able to make I think around
200 to 250k which isn't too bad at all
so going to go ahead and buy another one
and hopefully do the same thing all
right so there we go went ahead and got
a Ferro scepter bought so that was uh
pretty nice also seed off all of the
prayer potions I ended up making so
we'll go ahead and collect that try to
sell it back on and there we go so 10
minutes later we end up selling off the
Ferro scepter for a good 220k margin so
going to go ahead and buy another one
and hope that we can do the same thing
of course why not
what what no way dude okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
this is a great margin I do not care
that that insta bot for 600k more that
means someone's trying to dump these and
they shouldn't be because that's just
I'm going on another account right now
my other account and I'm grabbing as
many of these as I can so just give me a
second
please all right
oh it's pretty insane but I did end up
selling off that Ferro scepter for an
850k profit gonna go ahead and try and
do the same this one should be about
750k I'm just making sure that I'm
getting these so yeah I mean I I don't
know what to say this is just an insane
merch and I don't know how I'm getting
this but yeah all right so another Ferro
spor sold I don't know how long these
will keep up I wish I had more money so
that I could constantly have these
offers in but unluckily enough it isn't
the case but we'll keep going and if I
can keep getting these merchesi do it I
do have to go back to college here soon
so that's going to take like 2 hours to
get back there it's like an hour away
but I do have to go to my mom's house my
grandparents house just to stop by so
this margin might be gone by the time I
get back all right two more Mal or not
mal addiction Wards but two more odium
Wards to be made um going to be making
about 500k off of each one of these
again so another Mill which is insane
however uh odium W or odium Shard 3
prices have shot up so now you barely
make any money so I'll I'll I'll wait
until that they are better and hopefully
try to find some
all right so there will be a couple
times during this video where I will be
just recording over this is the one time
and this was a sick clue scroll well not
one time but I'll be doing a couple
times this was a sick clue scroll got a
Mill and a master clue on top of that
afterwards went ahead and finished off
Watchtower so there you go there is that
back into the live commentary all right
so there we go doing a little bit of
range almost got 61 I'm just afking
while I play a little bit of FIFA and
edit some videos but there we go got an
easy clue scroll going to go ahead and
do that now two steps in and there we go
we got a casket so let me put back on my
armor and boom okay well uh that's
actually a duplicate which is really
weird considering I've only done 8 easy
Clues but uh yeah I guess you know
didn't expect a whole lot but uh little
disappointed all right another two-step
clue and that one it was okay so that's
actually pretty good 97k we'll go ahead
and take that and there and there we go
another medium clue or easy clue
completed and I mean I guess it's
teleport so you know it's all right and
there we go another clue scroll so let's
go ahead and open it and we just keep
getting these things man stupid all
right so went back to my hell hound Tas
I kind of want to AFK these so decided
range would be the option and uh please
stay away for the love of
God okay okay
okay okay answer is 150 this is the
fifth step could be the clue reward and
it is and oh my God like it isn't like
insanely like High but that like three
different like oh that's insane there we
go I've gotten pretty good clue luck
thus far I won't lie there we go another
clue scroll
and rip it's looking like there's pretty
little hope at this point so uh yeah I
mean honestly should we just should we
just die right now or oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh I mean he's going to kill me God damn
it all right so do we drop this or
drop
that
H all right come on oh can I log out can
I log out can I log oh
yes [__] off all right so there we go
another uh Slayer test done just
chilling uh going to go get another task
here in a second got to uh run to the
bank though real quick no more PKS to
worry about anymore just chill and here
we go another assignment and Cal fights
I can do that that's not too shabby at
all all right just kind of had like a
crazy merch I don't know apparently
because odium WS need to be bought a ton
um odium shards 2 went up to 1.3 mil I
bought it at about 200k so that's just
insane they do have really big margins
right now though so I'm going to leave a
couple offers in for them at a lower
price and hope they buy but yeah I'm
going to look for a couple
merchesi rings I ended up getting my
margin back but then I couldn't end up
selling the other two which would have
been for about 120 to 30k profit each
but the these Samurai hats I bought in
total for
1.5 pretty much 1.6 mil and was able to
sell them out for 2.3 so that's an
insane margin on those I'm really happy
about that I may start flipping lowlevel
like clue items again I guess this is
like medium level but that's insane I
mean to be honest I was getting like
what 200k off of each one at least
that's that's crazy all right so as far
as the meres went uh the tanic Rings I
actually lost uh about 250k off of each
of them so that kind of negates the
samurai hat
merchesi as you guys can see I went
ahead and bought them for 12.23 mil and
uh there they go 12.49 so about 260k
profit not too bad um there's probably
better items than this I'll try to look
for now and there we go just hit 68
range um before I came here though I
guess I hopped worlds but uh I bought a
ring of nature for 12.1 hoping to make a
500K profit on that here in a second
right so there we go went ahead and got
70 range so uh going to go ahead and do
the easy clue now and um yeah I also
sold off the ring of nature so that's
pretty lit all right and in case you
were you know looking for confirmation
there's a 500K merch on the Ring of
nature which is pretty sick so uh I
don't know if we'll be able to do this
again but we'll find another item and
there we go that is the end of the easy
clue
so all right so decided to go do some
wood cutting just cutting some tee just
got 45 wood cutting I don't know how far
I'll go I probably want to get 60 at
some point and I probably won't take too
long so we'll see what we can do and a
little while later 50 wood cutting LIT
All right so we got up to 57 wood
cutting I have a medium clue scroll that
I'm going to do and uh yeah other than
that I don't know I'm trying to flip
some stuff at the moment but there's
really nothing going on with those so uh
might lost a little bit of money all
right we got this clue scroll again I
think this time we're actually going to
go ahead and do fiic trial since I've
kind of put it off for a little while so
going to go to the gym and uh once I get
back we'll do that so I ended up
merching some of the uh Team Cape Z's I
didn't make any money off of them just
cuz I had to resell them on and lost
1,000 off each of them but uh got an
odium Shard I should be able to make
about 300 400k off of each one I make
I'm probably going to try to buy another
one though right now and there we go
about 45 minutes later finished up fir
minute trials not too hard of a quests
but uh time to finish up the medium clue
so pretty happy I got this out of the
way though since uh it's a pretty good
Milestone I think by the way got 33 uh
agility and 28 thieving in case you're
wondering so closing on that 1K
Milestone all right so there we go I
ended up getting the casket
and all right that was definitely worth
it I'm happy I did the quest 400k we can
take that that's that's really good oh
my God just one more level I hate this
[__] course I hate it so
much all right so here we go time to get
40 agility and then I am done with this
course so pretty lit and uh there it is
so I'm probably going to go do some
other stuff while I addit another video
but for now there we are all right so
there we go just hit 5 mil XP also
pretty far off the uh 1,000 total at
this point but I think I'm going to go
ahead and get 50 cooking and then I'm
probably going to actually do some real
[__] so let's do it and there we go I
think I'm going to call that the end of
the cooking grind for a little bit we
ended up getting 55 I think I'm going to
go ahead and make a little bit more
money before we end off this video so uh
God damn it I swear to God I forget a
freaking knife every time I am out here
so
uh yeah back it a very familiar place if
you've been watching the series for the
last couple episodes here we are going
to make another odium Ward if I can
figure out where to put it there we go
so uh another odium W made this one's
probably about a three 3 to 400k profit
so not too shabby um as far as money
making on this account I really don't
know what to do other than just like
messing with margins and stuff like that
because I've never really had a low-l
account uh most of the things that you
do for like pvm based stuff like green
dragons and stuff like that definitely
isn't as efficient as I'd like it to be
since I can make some of the same
margins just doing flipping so um just
trying to figure out what I want to do
really and there we go went ahead and
sold off the old or the odium ward for
50 50k and uh there's about 300K margins
on them right now so I'll probably keep
trying to buy those I guess all right so
pretty big level we're about to get I'm
probably about to get 45 defense and uh
with that I'll be able to wear Berserker
Helm archers Helms and stuff like that
so uh if I can just hit that'd be cool
and there we go so Berserker Helm we got
some pretty sick gear right now now and
uh probably won't be working on defense
much more I don't really want to make a
zerker account I still have some quests
to do but low defense sounds kind of
cool and eventually I might just kind of
settle around 70 is probably the plan
all right so here we are pretty familiar
place and uh got two odium Wards I'm
going to be using so finish these off I
should be making about two about 250 to
350k per one depending on which one it
is um the prices of them kind of went
down a little bit and the uh odium shard
piece three didn't go down at all so uh
the margins went down a little bit but
still making a decent profit all right
so here we go going to get another task
I did just use uh cannon on my Cal
fights Tas but I only ended up using
like 300 cannon balls so it wasn't too
bad at all it's definitely worth it
considering it made the test just so
much more easier so going to go ahead
and get another
assignment and fire Giants that's
actually really good I might do this in
the uh catacombs as uh that just seems
like a better thing to do but uh we'll
see all right so this time ended up
doing three mal addiction Wards it's
kind of a lot more than I usually do I
like to keep it down to one or two so I
don't lose that much but uh I had three
bots so I figured I may as well go and
do it so uh there we go there's the
first one I should be making about 250k
off of each one of these so this is
another
750 isk in total so not too bad at all
then within a couple minutes all three
mal addiction WS sold off in the grand
exchange which is pretty cool um going
to go ahead and just buy three more
shards I guess um at this point I'm
probably making about about 300K I think
per one so that's not bad at all so I'm
definitely okay with that all right and
there we are finished up my fire Giants
task so got 47 Slayer also got I think
another strength level which means we
can go ahead and get the dragon dagger
or probably Rune is all we can use for
now but eventually on top of that got 70
HP and now up to 77 combat so going to
go ahead and get another assignment and
py fiends we've had these before they're
not too bad at all probably give us a
couple medium clue Scrolls too while
we're at it all right so there we go 12
140 tokens I feel like that'll be enough
for a little while so we'll move on from
here and start off on our Defender grind
hey there it is let's go only like 200
400 points in something like that all
right so this is uh this is I'm just
going to war you guys this is what
happens when uh you know you kill
cyclopses while you're recording another
video so get ready for that kind of
defend jagex and say not everything is
jx's Fault um in this scenario you know
maybe
but I was more so talking about like
just in general so I got another
Defender [__] I just kind of want to
come and clarify things I'm not going to
back up on anything God damn
it and there we go the long awaited Rune
Defender so you can go ahead and go get
dragon now probably going to have to
pray melee for those but yeah I mean I
can't wear Dragon but I may as well go
ahead and get it for the future you
[__] heard me you [__] all right so
another uh postom but this was a pretty
disgusting medium clue that I uh ended
up getting then went on to do a little
bit of Slayer I got infernal Mages that
was one of the longest tasks I've ever
done you'll see that in the future then
went on to do an easy clue nothing there
and
then all right didn't expect I'd see
this day uh the day I'm finally done
with this infernal Mage task and the day
that I'm watching Donald Trump be sworn
as president so yeah let's go ahead and
get another
task yeah I know really cringy right
people talking about politics gets you
all riled up doesn't it so here we go
for another task I'm at 66 almost 67
attack which is cool 71 HP and uh
closing in on 50 Slayer which is pretty
good uh we're doing all right not doing
too bad at all and 114 desert
lizards going to end my life real quick
all right so that only took about 15
minutes I thought that was going to be a
lot worse than it actually was and
cockatrices that is it's quite good I'm
happy I'm happy with that that one is uh
that one's good all right so from there
uh this I don't I don't know what was
going on I think my roommate was just
playing some 2K but I went on and did
some Slayer got like wall Beast it got
trolls next so it wasn't too bad at all
they made for some decent tasks and uh
bang those
out yeah you guys see me here a lot
don't you um first time in a while that
I've recorded just like my voice when
doing this so this kind of cool uh roomm
AG is out and about so right now this is
going to be the like second to last clip
of the video I know this video is kind
of dragged on at this point but this is
another inventory of three mal addiction
Wars Wards we're making about 400k on
each mal addiction Ward so this is 1.2
mil profit um right now there's more
profit on the odium wards about 130k
more so I'm going to start buying those
for the next video but uh yeah going to
go sell these on and then finish off
this video so uh stick with me and there
we go so went ahead and sold them off I
did say I was going to make 1.2 I made
1.1 cuz I insold them and you guys might
be asking why are you instelling them
because it it's it's more worth my time
to ins them and buy back more than it is
to wait to try to merch sell them cuz
that takes about 20 minutes and in that
time I could buy another mal addiction W
if I had the money so if I actually had
the money I I would yeah slowly sell
them but I don't so I'm going to go
ahead I don't have OS buddy bro anymore
so I think I'm just going to have to
kind of give you guys an estimate of
what my bag's worth at the end of each
video which kind of sucks but I should
be able to do what I'd imagine all right
so first inventory this doesn't include
any like of my biggest armor but this is
most of my bank so there we go that is a
17 I guess 16.9 mil I'll go ahead and
add these all up and another inventory
we'll go with
2.6 and another mil and the last
inventory is my clue scroll tab so
2.1 all right so that means we are up to
22.6 mil I'd say that's actually really
good progress um there's only going to
be more with these odium Wards and
malediction Wards as long as there's
margins I will be doing them I know you
guys maybe want to see some actual
medium level uh moneymaking content
realistically the way that I would
advise you guys to make money is kind of
the same way that I'm doing now if
you're a lowl work on your account but
at the same time do merching things that
I am doing if you guys want to know how
to find the easiest and best
[Music]
turn into a set so this includes odium
WS malediction WS it shows you how much
it costs to buy all of the pieces and
how much it is to sell so right now iron
trimmed set with a skirt you end up
making 370k off turning it into a set so
you buy all the pieces for 300K and you
sell them on for 670 which is insane and
just small stuff like that just do that
while you're doing real things and like
working in your account in the game and
eventually that that's definitely more
effective than any medium level money
making content that you're going to have
like green dragons and stuff like that
realistically if I wanted to do anything
I'd probably buy death runes because
it's just the best money that I could do
in the game as far as like you know not
merging so I mean there's no content
there and that's kind of why I stay away
from that stuff so nonetheless hope you
guys have a wonderful day if you guys
enjoyed the video make sure to leave a
like if you guys want to see my videos
as soon as I go live hit that sub button
down below if you guys want to tell me
anything uh leave it in a comment and uh
as always join 07 helpers and hit up my
Twitter in the description nonetheless
hope you guys have a wonderful day and
peace and uh episode three
[Music]
me